Aston Martin unveiled the iconic db9 in
late 2003 that was 12 years ago it was a
stellar car from the get-go but how do
you keep an already good car fresh you
introduce a GT version you fill it with
progressive new technology add some
badging and new 20-inch wheels alter the
front splitter and rear diffuser and
make it a teensy more expensive at just
under $200,000 it's barely more
expensive than the $191,000 standard
version and let's be honest it's not
that different if you look close the new
GT does have a subtle uplift and a
little cachet for the new year
the db9 GT has the same v12 engine that
its sister has and it roars to live like
a refined monster when you hit the gas
it gets to 540 horsepower on a 6-speed
automatic rear-wheel drive and there's
no hesitation as it jumps forward like a
bullet it hits 60 miles per hour and 4.5
seconds top speed is 183 miles per hour
did I mention the excellent suspension
can be set to normal sport and track
modes that will give you varying
stiffness in response for those nights
when you need to drive just like James
Bond standard on this GTR new carbon
ceramic Brembo brakes which are lighter
than before and a new trunk lid spoiler
the computer system inside matches the
uniform look of the interior
I love the unique streamlined stitching
along the roof the Alcantara wrap sport
steering wheel and the generous head and
leg room up front but don't even think
of trying to get someone in the backseat
they will hate you for life possibly the
best thing about this car is how perfect
it looks from every angle on the outside
it's totally masculine and feed-line
fit to the road like a bespoke suit but
as fluid as silk the black trim around
the headlights brake calipers and
optional carbon fiber tail light only
enhance the stunning effect
in fact I should warn you not to drive
this car at all if you don't want
attention but if you don't mind some
looks
you won't be disappointed with the db9
GT